in round 11. it's young christophe duda
who's been struggling this tournament
only nine points so far against the
niche geary winning two games in a row
so far today on fire with great air
quality probably what's happening in
this game david okay still early days in
this game we're jumping in just after
the opening so we haven't missed much um
this for viewers at home who are keen on
opening names this was the regauzing
defense i believe um so we've seen a
trade of a couple of pieces so far the
pawn structure however is slightly
imbalanced so
white has an extra pawn in the middle of
the board if you look at the two central
files the e and the d files white has
two pawns there black only has one so in
these types of positions white long term
has a small advantage but currently
black is well centralized black is well
developed rooks connected
everything else uh pretty much balance
so early days it's just going to be
about who understands the position
better who can again initiate that
action in a favorable way
and uh okay anish starts with a
mysterious rook move planting his rook
behind one of his own pawns this is
something we normally never ever
recommend rooks want to be on open files
but i guess black's idea is to move the
black knight out of the way and then
push the pawn in front of that black
rook that has just moved and he will
hope to open things up in that fashion
that is black's plan over the next three
or four moves it's a very clever move
right because it's kind of also
anticipating what uh duda is going to be
doing which is this pawn break you know
he's saying yep i'm going to open up
this line and anish is just going yeah
i'm going to be ready because you see
that pawn that is uh that the rook is
looking at that is a target
yeah i must admit i don't like the move
by black at all i mean i understand the
point behind it i think it's clever this
rook move uh because you want to as
mentioned uh move this knight out the
way and once this bishop retreats then
you push this pawn forward and suddenly
rook's opposite
opposite enemy queens it can be very
effective white queen unhappy here but
the reason i don't like ivanka is
because this move the bishop can land on
this square hitting the black rook and
you have to move it again you have to
lose time this rook's already moved once
two moves ago has to move again and okay
maybe this position is still fine for
black but you've lost time and i hate
losing time um in my games so
right now that is the dilemma facing
anish geary can he push this pawn
forward
he has moved his knight actually
so he is destined to lose time against
his rook because this bishop is going to
attack it
and uh if you have to move it again now
white can maybe start centralizing rooks
white can maybe just step the queen
forward one square step the pawn forward
white has one extra move compared to a
position he could otherwise have uh
otherwise have got so
yeah very strange uh maneuver there by
anishkiri and he has indeed moved his
rook for a second time in a few moves
wow
he has had a good day so far these are
the standings after
10 rounds out of 15 in the preliminaries
jana publicati on top with incredible 23
points we also see that vladislav
artemyev in eighth place currently
qualified for the knockout stage but
levonaroni and currently outside
and so is young christoph duda who has
uh struggled a little bit so far this
tournament anish geary he has a
very good day today currently now in
second place
must be the air quality today foreign
yeah so i think this includes the result
we just saw between magnus carson and
ding so imagine if level erroneous in
ninth place he's in great form in
general if he wins he will leapfrog both
those players in fifth and seventh place
if vladislava tamif in eighth wins he
will leapfrog them as well so magnus
sting
not feeling safe at all oh they really
need to up their game in the next few
rounds
yeah it's a strange
a little bit of a strange day something
going on maybe with magnus crossley has
been down with kovid that could
definitely be
a reason why he needed a little bit of a
break now before
round 12 final round of today that will
start in 50 minutes but first we're
gonna follow all the action here in
round 11.
both players leaning back looking at the
board is this a tense position it is
quite a tense position and actually
i realized there was quite a big threat
that there was a trap that anishigiri
had set one that i would maybe have
fallen into um if we just go into the
position briefly we can see that
anishigiri as black did have a sneaky
idea so white's most
natural move maybe most logical move
would be to improve one of these two
rooks they're not doing anything every
other piece has moved and is active but
if you move one of these rooks for
example if you activate this rook
swinging it across attacking this pawn
with the queen
and the rook now then black would have
pushed a pawn forward and trapped this
white bishop on the edge of the board
there's no retreat now for this bishop
this pawn is protected by black's bishop
and the queen will win this bishop on
the next turn so very very sneaky idea
that is why you always got to consider
your opponent's threats first thing you
look for in any position if your
opponent doesn't have a threat then you
can
kind of continue with your plans so this
move is what an issue once uh sorry judo
wanted to play but it wasn't possible so
he lifted up his queen and now black's
move isn't possible if the pawn pushes
now it would lose protection of the
knight white would simply win a piece
uh so very clever play by both sides and
uh yeah let's go back to the players i
expect to see white now centralize the
rooks if possible and i do prefer
white's position because level pawns but
white has extra pawns in the middle of
the board
and compared to flank pawns
pawns on either side uh central pawns
are more important in the middle game
especially while queens are on the board
all right after that quick draw i'm
feeling a little bit
down
so i i have a little bit of a negative
question because we keep talking about
the importance of great air quality you
know you can you can think faster you
can think better
how bad can we
can it go if you have really bad air
quality and i mean like is it deadly
if you want to talk about death yeah you
could uh end up there but uh there's
definitely a long path
that's good to hear yeah uh long term uh
we do know that things like radon have a
big impact could lead to pneumonia
cancer a lot of things uh
in worse cases so but but i mean
first thing is to actually monitor the
air yeah why worry
until you actually know that the indoor
air is is bad but high levels of
particulates like particles in the air
uh radon those are kind of things uh
chemicals in the air that actually goes
into your body and out your bloodstream
and
thereby could impact your overall health
yeah
for sure i for example love lighting
candles you know dark norway it's so
nice i just i you know in the night i
can light 20 candles all over my
apartment and that must be kind of bad
that's not a good thing yeah i know
i'm sorry to say yeah what about uh not
candles but uh the scent scent diffusers
you know it's the same thing really yeah
because you're releasing
you're releasing things in the air right
so it's still the same concept
unfortunately
which is why when you work with indoor
equality like i do all the lights at
home is is electric
uh-huh even the you know the camel ones
yeah or electric
uh so you get a bit paranoid uh if you
work in the industry yeah i can imagine
what was the what was like when you
started working with air things what
sort of things did you change in your
home environment
i think the first of all was just to
you know be very very very paranoid yeah
in general and make sure that we have
fresh air all the time so when we looked
at buying a house it was super important
to have uh balanced ventilation to bring
out that was like the number one
criteria
schools for the kids all that other
stuff not important
we need good air yeah you know windows
to open and just balance there is it is
it better with the newer buildings
rather than buying it it's better with
newer buildings if you have balanced
ventilation because that's that's one of
the things right you some people have
heard about sick building syndrome which
means that you build more airtight
buildings houses so you don't actually
you know you don't get rid of all the
indoor chemicals which is why
ventilation is super important
so there was a time when you know we
modernized we got more airtight
buildings but the the the ventilation
the capability of getting fresh air in
wasn't the top priority
uh so
new houses new buildings with
proper ventilation yeah that's the best
okay
well my apartment is quite new so i'm
glad you hear that even if i light a lot
of candles uh-huh i live in an old house
but aren't they meant to breathe you
know all houses do breathe so that's a
different difference so you do have
small cracks small openings
um
energy leakage but but you do get some
natural ventilation which is same for
cabins
and things like that as well yeah
bad news in a storm though
the whole building shakes
all right i do hear some moves coming
out david what's happening on the board
so a few moves but nothing too special
has happened
right now just jumping forward with the
knight trying to attack one of the black
pawns and ivanka whose position do you
prefer personally i slightly prefer
whites but you could make an argument
for both sides here um i
white has the center i'm a big fan of
that
and but i do like anish's last move
which was also my instinct which is just
to centralize the bishop and just to
lengthen the scope of this diagonal look
at where it's pointing to it's pointing
towards the white king and uh now
it's going to be a question for duda
what how does he deal with this active
piece does he
take measures to kick that bishop back
or is he perhaps just going to play
around as magnificent that bishop's
magnificence and do something else
yeah that is a big question that's the
pressing question for duda right now and
duda is not in form he hasn't won in the
last two days so he will be slightly
worried about any potential attack
against his king often if you're not in
great form you start to see ghosts you
start to over protect your king or start
to worry a bit a bit too much about your
opponent's ideas and you could imagine
for example the black queen starting to
line up against the white king and
suddenly it would be disastrous so
for sure some of those ideas in mind
about trying to eliminate this black
bishop you can do that in two ways
one which is a bit loose a bit risky but
could be very effective would be to push
this ball forward next trying to push
another pawn forward trying to create
that strong pawn center for example if
black just moves you could push again
forward attacking this bishop but the
problem is once this bishop moves
there are a few squares for it
protected now by the black knight now
these pawns are a bit loose especially
this guy in the center it's attacked
twice by black's queen and by the rook
behind it and it's not so easy to defend
so this one has pros and cons pushing
white's pawns forward that's the problem
with pawns they don't step backwards and
uh they never cover squares that they
lose track of i was about to say the
second way to get rid of this bishop is
to trade it off with a piece uh rather
than attack it with a pawn and duda is
going to try and do that he's retreated
his night that night looked very nice
and pretty in the center but now his
idea is that for example if black swings
the queen across threatening a checkmate
against this square using the queen and
bishop together then white can solve
that problem and go on the attack at the
same time defend and attack hitting this
queen now with the knight hitting the
bishop but more importantly defending
this square as well and now next move
once the black queen runs from this
attack you're guaranteed to eliminate
black's best piece and if this piece
disappears black is left with a rather
sad knight on the edge of the board and
actually
if this happens for example a trade here
this knight sorry this knight is uh
simply
destined to stay
on the edge of the board for probably
the rest of the game it's that bad a
piece it's actually dominated by white's
bishop and white's queen there's nowhere
really safe for this knight to go so
that is dude's plan he wants to relocate
his night round and eliminate the black
bishop takes a while but it will be very
effective if he can make it happen yeah
and uh what's quite nice is that the
queen is located on that uh c3 square
because black really wants to trap that
uh bishop that's sitting there all by
itself
but as long as the queen is sitting on
that particular dark square black cannot
push the desirable um
b6b5 pawn yep white's queen just keeping
an eye on that black knight and
yeah it's very tense position this one
despite the computer saying 0.1 being
roughly in the middle all three results
possible anything can happen um it just
means that there's chances for both
sides right now and
anish leaning forward slightly lower on
the clock as well you can tell he's not
entirely happy with his position i also
saw anish those co2 levels
rising a lot today throughout the day
and uh talking about uh co2 levels muay
reach on twitter says well on a selfie
that air things is giving him there in
aberdeen the green light
and they also want to see the return of
the original play magnus chess set they
want to buy it ah the the
plastic black and white one exactly
it's very very nice and it's very very
popular on social media yeah yeah
they are very nice they're easy to carry
around yeah look at that
look at that yeah that's beautiful
green light and it's a wave as well this
is the magic one where you just wave at
it and everything is okay
and uh we do have a move from anish he's
just developed his rook
pointing it on a semi-open line and uh
also we got a big hello from calvin who
is watching from kenya ah that's so cool
that everyone is watching from different
parts of the world and uh he also says
that he loves our commentary thank you
kelvin thank you yeah we really love
having you with us and if you two want
to share your selfies you want to send
us any questions or any questions about
chess or even about air quality because
we are very lucky to have you come here
on hand to help us then you can tweet us
using the hashtag chestcharms definitely
do that everyone and uh we have
something else
to uh say to you as well that you should
do you can uh we've launched something
called tour badges this season so for
every tournament there's going to be a
new badge and with every badge comes
load loads of perks that you can gather
so if you go into chess 24 um
the slash tour
badges you can read more about this and
start
collecting those
badges which is very cool imagine to
have all nine badges
have you collected them yet david these
badgers yeah not yet because you're
commentating right exactly yeah but
maybe when i go home later i'll collect
them but no i'm loyal to pokemon cards
those are the only ah yeah did you
collect that i did yeah i did too yeah i
also collected spice girls photos and uh
did you have the pogs in england
pogs yeah i love the pogs
okay so anyone at home with a uh
penchant for collecting things yeah
what did
i had this spice girls photos did you
it's a scandinavian thing probably then
probably yeah very much likely uh with
the album and then you could buy a new i
bought a new package of photos every
saturday i got like 20 kroners to go buy
a package i still have them i'm um
yeah i might sell them and you know get
the pension money at some point yeah
exactly they're going to be worth
loads of money well some pokemon cards
are yeah exactly yeah
all right it feels like this game is a
little bit slow so far david will it
explode at some point yeah we're still
waiting for that moment that braveheart
moment yeah for the game to explode
there is currently a threat in the
position uh black's knight has just
jumped in attacking one of the white
rooks so um
i feel like maybe gary is trying to be
the more ambitious ambitious of the two
right now that being said duda can just
move that rook there are plenty of safe
squares and i don't think there will be
too much to worry about for him not too
much damage to the white position and
this is why you always want a strong
center
as white or as either color because even
if things go wrong if you have a strong
center like this that white has
you know you won't be in too much danger
so uh we saw this knight attack the rook
and now the rook has just sidestepped
one square and this is quite an
instructive moment i don't think greed
is good here black can actually go and
grab a pawn this pawn is isolated
it's social distancing very much so from
the rest of its pawns but if black gets
greedy and grabs it then it would be
disastrous for example okay this hasn't
happened i got a heart attack for a
moment that giri had made this blunder
but the white knight could now just jump
forward defending this bishop but more
importantly removing the defender this
bishop now of black's knight and look at
these two pieces this queen is pretty
much trapped ready to be uh picked off
maybe by a white rook later and also
this is a deadly pin the black knight
cannot move because the queen would drop
behind it so greed sometimes is not good
and uh anishigiri has played a tricky
move he pushed his pawn forward and the
idea is now that if rook takes knight we
keep coming on up on this theme
now if we saw a trade here it would be
bishop and knight in exchange for a rook
the bishop at night would be better but
anish has a trick in mind after rook
takes knight on this square pawn takes
pawn would be a bit annoying because now
the queen needs to defend its rook and
if you take this pawn back with your
pawn instead then there might be some
trouble rook takes rook and suddenly
some back rank checks against white's
king which doesn't have much breathing
space you have to take back with the
knight and after a trade on this square
i know this is a lot of moves but at the
very end we see yes it's still bishop
knight for a rook
but now it's easier for black to play
because the rook and queen connect but
these two pieces are so far away from
each other they will struggle to
coordinate and i think black would be
fine in this position
so yeah complicated stuff tricky from a
niche this pawn push has initiated the
action we wanted
but will do to allow it how many steps
did you go there i mean usually
strategic very uh yeah many moves ahead
yeah that's the thing actually we talk
about calculation in chess like looking
forward um trying to work out my move
then my opponents move then my move my
opponents move and it's easier to do
when it's all forcing so if i just walk
through that again very very slowly um
so here it's a capture which is one of
the most forcing moves in chess apart
from a check it's the most forcing then
it's another capture and a threat and
then it's another capture and then it's
another capture so every move is forced
there's no options for either side so
it's easier to work out i mean some
positions there's five options for white
five replies for black here everything
is forced and now black has to take this
rook otherwise you're a piece down white
has to recapture otherwise white is down
material now black has to capture this
pawn i mean it's a free pawn and we're
actually maybe heading in this direction
so this um to answer your question was
this to answer your question was four
moves each in uh
so eight moves in total ahead but the
players they're capable and this is
about to happen on the board and they're
capable of finding this thing uh this
type of thing so uh yeah a long
variation we often say is a wrong
variation you don't want to calculate
too far ahead unnecessarily especially
if there's lots of branches lots of
alternatives but
sometimes play can be very forcing but
at some point uh these forcing moves
will be over i guess we're here now so
now what now that's the question now
it's no longer forced now both sides
have options again so that's where i
would stop my calculation if i'm looking
in advance yeah and this in this
position you know we would try to have
it in our mind's eye
and then we would try to evaluate and
all those things that david was talking
about you know the combination of bishop
and knight would they be working well
and what about your opponent's rook how
valuable is that and then take a look at
the pawn structure that anish giri has
he has if you look at one of his pawns
it's unchallenged it's a two versus one
poor majority and that means there's a
potential to create a past pawn can
these two pieces that duda has can they
hold off that rook and that pawn and
that's the kind of questions that we
would ask ourselves it's kind of like
step back and look at the view so we've
kind of gone into the whole kind of
calculations gone into that deep dark
forest come out of it take back look at
the view and uh
duda took a look at it and he goes yeah
i think this is fine um gary i think
he's looking quite positive actually
from from my reading of his body
language he looks like yep okay he's in
the zone he thinks that he has the
chances to push
cool
anish geary he is on fire today he has
won two games so far young christophe
duda has struggled in this tournament
but uh young christoph duda he won the
world cup about six months ago and is
ready for the candidates anish geary
what chances do you give him to qualify
for the candidates not many spots left
not many spots left but anishgiri he
didn't take part in the first grand prix
event so he's got two grand prix events
if he does well in both he'll qualify
it's not easy though in those types of
knockout tournaments it becomes a bit of
a lottery everyone is so good one bad
game and your chances could be gone so
anish he's been in training mode he's
mentioned it on twitter he loves to
tweet and um yeah
he's ready he wants this chance at the
world championship but look at this last
move he's offered now a trade of queens
and i think white should try to avoid
that at all costs if you trade the
queens off the board then suddenly
black's two versus one majority in terms
of pawns that ivanka mentioned that will
become maybe the biggest factor in the
position the the white knight and the
white bishop they are starting to
combine now near each other at least but
they will struggle to stop black's pawns
if they are not assisted by a queen so
that's why white keeps the queens on the
board um often if you have a kind of
diagonal piece like a bishop a kind of
tricky piece like a knight you need a
lateral piece a piece which controls
files and lines like a queen like a rook
in order to make them kind of achieve
their full potential so
if you just have a knight and bishop
alone they can struggle against a rook
but if you have a queen if you have a
rook they can be fantastic pieces later
in the game yeah and now it's harder for
black to push those two pawns forward
white's queen will stop them and i just
wanted to kind of elaborate a little bit
on david's point with the bishop and the
knight okay so anish is insistent that
he wants to swap off those queens and uh
these this bishop and a knight they work
well as attacking pieces so because of
the color of the bishop it's light
squares
the knight and the bishop are forced to
attack on the light squares so they're
going to work together and ideally to
get a mating attack or they will need to
work with the queen so a dream scenario
for duda would be if he somehow manages
to launch harry up the board
fix those light squares around the king
and somehow this is this somehow kind of
like improve this the diagonal of the
bishop and
introduce a mating attack towards the
king and it's just light squares just
think of something happening on the
light squares and that's that's the
dream that you can see dave has
highlighted it
that's definitely one of the plans long
term if duda can achieve it but it does
take a while first you need uh one move
to get your queen out of the possible
trade and then you need black to maybe
do nothing and then as you mention your
anchor you need to create some space for
your king uh maybe launching this pawn
up the board so that the king can
breathe some fresh air and um then next
then you need to move your bishop out
the way but at the moment the queen is a
bit overstretched she has to defend her
knight at the bottom of the board she
has to avoid any possible trades we
could well see a scenario where this
queen just kind of lifts her skirts and
runs away but she gets challenged every
time the black queen will follow her
around the board and uh the queen and
rook teaming up remember the trades
favor black so wherever the white queen
goes black will follow wherever the
white queen retreats black will follow
and it's not clear where the queen will
escape to without allowing that trade
so you think it's going to be a draw
just by this queen dance like he's going
to say swap queens white's going to say
no
and the dance will continue until the
end of time struggling to see what else
white can do simply so after this queen
move i think anish has found a great
defensive motif note how the white
bishop as well cuts off the black pawns
from advancing so black has nothing else
to do except for play this kind of
chasing game of the queens so
yeah dude he'll be looking for ways to
keep the queens alive okay he does go to
this square lining it up on the light
squares possibly
but black i'm pretty sure is going to
chase that queen with his own queen you
can go back to this square to try and
challenge you can also go back maybe to
this square and try and challenge and uh
yeah it's still roughly balanced
i think i would prefer white if anyone
just because of the potential of the
bishop knight when they do improve later
but
right now black's pieces they combine so
well and still that poor majority the
two versus one long term that is
something in the bank for gary to hope
for they're also very equal on the clock
it's just it feels like it's a little
bit calm before the storm in this game
it just feels like it yeah i'm hoping
dude i mean he is a fighter actually his
online chess handle when he plays blitz
is polish fighter 3000. really yeah so
he he calls himself a fighter so
hopefully he won't do whatever
ding and magnus did and just repeat the
position three times and go for that
draw hopefully he'll uh find a way to at
least avoid the queen trade and keep the
game alive and duda has to do that i
mean if he doesn't win this game i think
he's got no more chances
i mean he's uh he's lost five games
already in this tournament duda and he's
really really struggling his fighting
chess index is uh a little bit over 63
out of 100.
what is a good number david you know
this fighting chess index is very new to
us so it's it's still hard to know to
evaluate what the numbers mean 63 yeah
so it's it's out of 100 so that's that's
decent in terms of attacking um kind of
fighting chess at least um the top
players in the tour that we've seen
they're slightly over 70 that means that
they really push for every game for
every result often playing long long
games to try and win um so i would say
over 60 is
decent but over 70 that's a really good
okay
fighting chess so we'll get to know more
about those fighting chess stats as the
tour continues as we get more of a
sample size
of games but either way um dude's score
of 63 is decent and uh he will hope to
improve that
meanwhile i'm slightly surprised maybe
giri is playing for the win maybe he
doesn't want the draw maybe he's
smelling blood that duda is not informed
this tournament and he's not chasing the
white queen instead he's going after
that lonely white pawn on the left look
at that black queen she's lined herself
up with the white king but also hitting
that white pawn
so yeah maybe giri getting ambitious do
you like the decision
uh i would be scared to play a move like
that as black just because i saw a safer
option and
i would be scared of white's pieces
suddenly kind of springing out of the
box the night bishop
as you mentioned yeah kind of joining
the white queen in attack but then again
if you're both getting low on time it's
kind of a tricky move
you are creating threats
i like it i i don't like it at all i
think it would have been much safer to
chicken out and just uh try to offer the
trade of queens all the time because the
thing kind of thing that i'm worried
about is that the night will just move
itself away and
this is the key thing i have a feeling
it might anchor itself and sit on a
central square protecting the bishop
and uh once it does this so uh david can
highlight where i want my knight to go
it wants to go to the e3 square
and then once it does this okay so we
could seeing it there and once it's done
this
protected the bishop kind of solidified
the placing of the king then you can get
on with the plan that i dreamt about all
those moves ago you know creating some
air for the king
moving the king into safety and then
just
just torturing black on the light
squares yeah just to show the uh
long-term plan if white can get the king
off the first rank out of the eye line
of the black queen then suddenly this
bishop is no longer pinned it's free to
enter the action and it will have
targets
on the light squares so yeah this will
be a very weak point we actually saw
this pawn be a big weakness in previous
days on the tour and uh look at this the
white knight has found that square
ivanka mentioned um if we go to the game
actually it has come at the cost of this
pawn black has just gobbled up another
pawn so these are
past pawns now they're gonna run down
the board if they can they're still far
far away from causing any danger but
white will bring the bishop into the
attack and already another rhyme we've
coined knights on f5 will thrive it's
possible for white's knight to jump to
this dream f5 square and suddenly look
at this black king there are no pieces
around it to defend and suddenly the
knight is attacking already threatening
to jump in with a check and what we call
a fork double attack but also once the
queen joins once the queen joins this
knight there are going to be some clear
checkmating threats two attacking pieces
no defending pieces around the black
king
now it's a big big risk that gary has
taken i think gary wants to win this
game rather than just draw but look at
this the white knight has indeed jumped
forward and
suddenly this king is really hearing the
warning signs yeah there's a there's not
only checkmating ideas in the air but
there's also a knight jumping into the
e7 square to deliver what we call a fork
that would be uh yeah i i think this is
a game where uh it's you know for a
beginner in chess you can just sort of
see the white pieces better placed like
the black piece is on the edges so
scattered around and it seems the white
pieces are just working better together
yeah exactly imagine if the white bishop
somehow joins the action as well then
that's why we say knights and bishops
together are often better than a rook so
there's simply two of them uh two pieces
are better than one and uh alone they're
worth less than a rook together they're
worth much more and giri maybe suddenly
realizing that there are a lot of
threats to contend with
and he has to move either his brook or
his king right now because of that
knight check idea the knight jumping in
to attack them both at the same time
one of them has to move but do you
really want to move the black king
it doesn't look like many safe squares
there and if you move the black rook
instead where do you put it
you could swing it the whole way across
sitting next to the black king that's a
good defensive square but white would be
able to start creating some checkmate
threats already with the white queen
remember queen and knight together are
the dream attacking combo the knight is
the only piece that does stuff that the
queen cannot yeah and the black queen
totally offside yeah that's another okay
the black king has shuffled off to the
corner onto a dark square slightly safer
but yeah that's one theme again we've
seen throughout the episode
that's one thing we've seen throughout
the year that things must is the black
queen being offside leads to attacks and
wow look at this a nice sacrifice by
duda he is really working all the angles
right now and we have to show this on
the board this is a trick the knight
actually giving itself up for a key
defensive pawn but if the black king
takes it the sneaky idea is that the
queen shuffles across with a check but
it's a double attack chess is all about
double attacks and next move once the
king moves out of the check the rook
simply drops off and white has an extra
bishop once it joins the action it's
gonna be deadly um it also it will end
up on a light square eventually hitting
the black king so this move this knight
now is poisoned
and if you can't take it
your king is going to be doomed whatever
you do now is black if you try and bring
the queen back into the defense then the
white knight steps back and suddenly the
king is vulnerable on the dark squares
as well as the light squares
uh what a spot what a tactic what a
trick by doodah yeah i loved your line
working all the angles and it's so true
you know diagonals and uh there's
straight lines but uh if i were in uh
anisha's spot
uh i probably would capture the night
and i would i would just take it because
this three is the magic number when it
comes to checkmating attacks and i don't
want three pieces attacking me so
therefore okay he's gone for something i
was kind of hoping that the queen and
bishop wouldn't coordinate well okay
instead the black queen dropped back but
look at this the white knight does
simply retreat the black queen is
plugging the holes on the dark squares
but all white needs to do is give his
king some breathing space give it some
fresh air um you don't want to move your
bishop away and walk into some nasty
background checkmates the king has no
escape squares now so you'd have to drop
your bishop back again uh but once you
give this king some breathing space for
example uh pushing a pawn forward next
move no matter what black okay he does
this no matter what black does you bring
your bishop into the attack and now if
you move your knight out the way again
there'll be deadly threats along this
diagonal and as ivanka said three is the
magic number there's three attacking
pieces there's only really one defender
so uh this is going to be winning these
pawns are too slow these black pawns
they take an age to march down the board
white white's attack is far quicker only
red numbers on the black king's air
things device then i think yeah co2
levels around that platform
and the co2 levels around the white king
have suddenly dropped with that
breathing space that's what porn move
has just given it
it's like opening a window
pushing your pawn
getting some luft around your king and
look at young chris of duda you know
he's been leaning back the whole game
looking quite chill now he's leaning
forwards
yeah you know he's a huge change in body
language like you say because before it
looked like okay this wasn't my
tournament i'm just gonna play make some
moves then suddenly okay maybe i can get
back into it yeah after all
it's not how you start it's how you
finish exactly and three points for a
win it's going to take him to 12 points
it's not going to be over for young
christoph duda he can still qualify for
the knockout stage with a fantastic
finish to the tournament to the
preliminaries and he's one of those
players for him it's all about momentum
we saw in the world cup once he gets one
or two results
he continues rolling um some other
players they're very consistent
sometimes they'll make a draw they'll be
solid and they'll take a win here there
and uh duda once he wins one game he
often wins several in a row so um yeah
i'm just okay black's still in big
trouble here but i'm just backtracking
to that one moment i said i like the
fighting spirit behind it but it was
that moment dude gary stopped chasing
the white queen he had to continue that
harassment of the white queen try and
get the queens off the board because
without queens black's king will never
ever get checkmated
so that's just instructive for everyone
at home if you're scared of an incoming
attack swap those queens off the board
and uh you'll be much safer but
giri now
yeah he's making some uh gestures
wincing he's not happy at all white's
bishop can already join the action
um there's not a r okay it chooses
slightly strange square just holding up
the advance of black's pawns
but not an attacking square for that
bishop yet
i'm surprised by that one actually i
thought that uh he would simply align
the bishop and the queen threaten
checkmate maybe we're too hasty maybe
he's just playing the slow patient game
he'll stop the advance of those black
pawns he'll improve maybe the white king
push some of those white pawns forward
and then he'll go for the black king
yeah i i'm surprised as well i must
admit
he's much more controlled than we are
but
either way still a strong position for
white
intense well the bar has gone slightly
down and it's jumping back up again it's
not over i suppose but giri is fighting
hard for a draw here yeah it's not over
but then again sometimes we talk about
the evaluation bar sometimes it might
say plus five for white but it's only
one move only one opportunity but this
is the type of position it says plus two
plus three but it's a long-term
advantage unless you make a huge mistake
it's going to stay around plus one plus
two plus three for a long long time uh
you still need to find the killer blow
that is the hard part but uh yeah it's a
long-term advantage for him and like you
say you know he has all the time in the
world just to improve his bishop you
know not even even proving he can just
move his bishop move his knight get
those extra minutes seconds on the clock
and uh anish
begging
duda for a queen trade but of course
it's not going to happen pigs will fly
before duda takes those queens off
but and with the queens on the board and
only about a minute on the clock i mean
it must be
there must
be possible to blunder for both i guess
in this position definitely that's
that's the only thing that could do to
trade the queens is that the risk of a
blunder uh becomes a bit less but then
again if the queens disappear blacks two
pawns unrivaled two pawns on the left
side would start running down the board
so
yeah partly for your own attack partly
um just because they the queen combines
so well with minor pieces he will keep
the queens on and look at this he dives
into the black position attacking
we talked about isolated pawns that
black pawn
next to the white queen is isolated
is uh a target now black's queen can
defend it
but
some big threats incoming
okay ivanka what do you think the black
queen will retreat has to retreat she
has to start just doing some repair work
and just filling in those holes like you
say and
i think
duda has his pickup moves he can do
whatever he likes you know he can just
retreat his queen and say maybe i'm
going to try a different direction or he
can try to improve the bishop
yeah white's bishop looks nice and
pretty uh stopping the black pawns from
moving but he needs to join the attack
um the white knight nicely placed as of
both attacking and defensive piece the
white queen active
also very nicely placed but the white
bishop is the only one that's not really
combining with the other two pieces
so how to improve that white bishop
less than 30 seconds for young christof
duda
how is he under time pressure and and
with speed chess yeah he's he's decent
he's maybe not in the same bracket as
magnus carlsen hikaru nakamura when it
comes to one minute three-minute chess
but
he's won some big blitz events i think
he came uh joint first at the world yeah
at the world blitz he ended up losing
the tie break there to maxim vashi
lagrave um he's came second in the world
blitz actually previously as well so one
of the best blitz players in the world
but
um yeah obviously with 16 seconds 18
seconds on your clock
it's uh not easy nobody can avoid
mistakes in that type of situation look
at the queen the dance between the
queens as well black begging as your
anchor said for that queen trade just
chasing the white queen around the board
but no trade will ever ever happen
no white's queen we'll just sidestep uh
we'll retreat yep yeah we'll retreat and
you know the night will get ready to
launch itself into the center square so
it has eight
squares available eight is a lot of
squares david eight
it is a lot of squares um so that's why
you called it an octa knight right yep
um
knights in the middle of the board they
do have these tentacles just eight
covering eight squares on the side of
the board they only cover four that's
why we say nice in the room at them um
so white's night nicely placed now but
could be even better placed in the
middle
um
yeah so
i'm expecting well i don't know what i'm
expecting for anishgiri i barely see a
move that defends here you have to move
maybe the black rook is going to say um
attacking white's bishop but duda just
exhaling there again his
uh kind of instincts that are tingling
that there's a knockout blow maybe the
white bishop just moves just retreats
just retreats it maybe attacks the rook
and yep keeping things simple
and the black rook has to move now
which direction is it going yes it's
kind of tricky isn't it
do you go on the aggressive must attack
the queen and he's done that but
i don't know there's no coordination
anymore it's not defending the king yeah
so for example the back rank now that
the eighth rank the top row is
vulnerable because the rook has
evacuated it and black's king did get
checked
it's now forced out of its hiding place
out into the open
and it's got a retreat now back where it
came from and now the knight will join
into the action it would launch itself
on e5 and start looking at the f7 pawn
look at it it's going to fall there's
nothing for it yeah that black queen is
hit
the black pawn as you mentioned is hit
on the f7 square the key square of f7
that we've mentioned a few times
i mean black's rook could give itself up
for the white knight but the white
knight protected by white's queen and
now black's queen forced off onto the
edge
i mean
there's plenty of moves that i think are
winning here you can even just push a
pawn up and attack the black queen
attack the black rook at the same time a
double attack
yeah that's the move we want
that's the loaf we see
uh yup that's a fork and geary he's
about to lose his rook he leans back but
he's not giving up yet this is good we
never want to see players give up we
want to see the checkmate we want to see
that end the game so black's rook it's
gone uh it's gone crazy and sacrificed
itself it was dropping anyway but
ah on that note giri does resign
was about to take that rook or could
even stepped up the board and that would
have been game over wow